You
but I think it'll be extremely enjoyable for everybody involved, at least visually,
you know, at least visually. I'm making sure my webcam is in place and that everything
is good. I'm quite anxious to show you what I've come up with. It actually wasn't my
intention at all, but it literally, after I woke up, it just idea just popped into
my head about kind of how to raise the hand cam experience for the visual stuff and the
visual effects and so I think you guys will like it a lot. I'm super super super excited.
I haven't tweeted yet, no, because I wanted to make sure I was good, but let me tweet
out that I'm live. Where is the tweet? Where did it go? Literally after I tweeted, it popped
into my head and I immediately tweeted it out and I immediately tweeted it out because
I wanted to hold myself accountable that I would do it because I'm like this is such
a good idea, I have to. Like why? I can't try to be lazy and avoid doing it because I had
to go get stuff to do this. Please, if you guys have enjoyed this week and you're new
here but you haven't subscribed, please consider subscribing. I put a lot of effort into the
videos I make when they're hand cam based, so I would appreciate the support. And obviously
it doesn't have to be monetary, but I mean just like liking, commenting, subscribing.
There's a lot to help my channel, so I really appreciate it. I also know in advance I'm
going to be very, very quiet because I am far away from the mic and I'm whispering unless
I come up super, super, super, super close to you, okay? So, you don't have to tell me
I'm quiet. I know, thank you. I'm just saying that in advance. There was one more idea that
I had, but I did not have time to put it into place, but I'll gladly tell you what it was
because it was part of the role play portion. You know how Mercy with her debut kind of
like captured you and like brought you and like you like woke up somewhere? Like I was
going to do something similar to that, but I would, I was going to show me like dragging
you in a bag and you like looking up and all the, all you see is just like kind of like
darkness and then like my circle is like a little circle of my face is a light and I'm
just looking down at you. And but I didn't, I didn't have time to put that together. Hold
on. Give me, give me, give me one. Yeah, I can always use it another time. I'm just very excited.
Sorry if you can hear, you know, she's singing the song of her people in the bathroom, not
like in a litter box. I mean, like she just like stood me out a lot. Okay, give me one
second. I need to do one more thing. Rain is a familiar.
Yeah.
Okay, I apologize. I just wanted to make sure that Fio was okay before I started because
I tend to get really into my ASMRs and I just want to make sure that she was nice and comfy
and good to go before I left her by her home some for an hour or two. These are all booth
assets except for my hat. I will, after I'm done the stream, I will credit what I've used
today in the description. So you guys can find it if you are wanting to use some of the
assets for Halloween yourself. I'm out of breath because I just ran around my house.
I also have some background sound. I have some storms. Please let me know if you think
that is okay. If you want to hear the storms or if it is too loud or if you would just
prefer the ambiance of simply me talking. I personally love storm backgrounds myself,
yes, as well. So let me know. Storm is cozy. Is it too loud or anything? Please do let me
know if it is too loud. Cozy, yeah. Alright, everybody seems pretty pleased with it. Alright,
cool. So I have some visual triggers prepared for you today. I might be actually too eager
to save the best for last because I just really want to show you guys what I've done. I'm pretty
proud of it. You thought the bowl with the water and the beads were good, but I got more
stuff for you. I have more on top of that. But yeah.
With super level of it. But yes, I'm very excited. I worked hard in the process. I'll give you a hint.
I've accidentally made, I turned water into a different form when I didn't mean to. There
might be a little bit of a science aspect to all of this which is going to be pretty fun
and neat. So I hope you guys will enjoy. I work really, really hard for you guys. I really do
because I really want to elevate my content and make stuff enjoyable. So I'm very proud
of what I've put together today. Yes, I'm Jesus. I have turned water into wine. It is true. It is,
all you've heard, it is real. Okay, I'm going to come up a little bit closer to you. Just a little bit
closer. Hi. I'm a little red. Let me just, there we go. Hi. Oh, Boomi's already here. Can you move,
sir? You need to leave. What are you scared of? There's nothing there. He's scared of my shoe. You
know, he's a special kind of guy, to be honest with you. Raina's in the litter box next to
me so I'm waiting for her to finish. Mam, are you done? Boomi, what are you scared of? Oh, you're
scared of my, well, you know, I'm actually good, I'm happy that you're scared of that
but I don't want you touching it. My part of the surprise, he is scared of. Raina, are you done? Mam,
that litter is not on the side of the thing. Well, you got some ASMR from Raina, from Raina in the
litter box.
Actually, I drank a drink that was left over. I thought it was new. It was not. It was a drink I
looked out for a bit. That's not good. Don't worry, it's fine. Don't worry, I'm okay. Got my
spooky cat. Also, before we start, I have to show you something because I'm very mad. I'm
extremely frustrated. Hold on. I'm going to switch over to the hand cam really quickly.
Okay.
Well, you can guess what I was saying, right? That I hate them. Did you see how ugly it was? Can you believe that? I know I was
muted. I could see that I was muted. Can you believe how ugly that thing was? That was an ugly baby. That one's
dying. That one's dying. He's not cute. He's so ugly. Why does he look like that? Why do all of my
children look ugly? I'm going to blame you. Anyways, so Raina's finally exited the litter box. So now I will
start the ASMR, okay? Alright. Okay.
Oh. Finally, you've woken up. You're probably wondering where you are, aren't you? It must be pretty weird
being in an unfamiliar place and waking up not knowing where you are. Who might I be, you ask? Don't worry about it. You
know, if I revealed my name to you, then you might have some sort of power over me. You don't really remember
anything, do you? You're in my realm now. You walked right into my trap. You really can't remember
anything. Not even how you wandered into my woods late at night. The dead of night. Not a star in the sky, the moon
could not be seen. Dark clouds hovering overhead. You don't remember the fog curling around your
ankles, working its way up your body, wrapping around your legs, reaching up, up, up, lingering
around your torso and enveloping you completely. You don't remember as you wander deeper into
the forest. Your eyes obscured. You don't see or call seeing my form in the distance. This
light shadow pulling you closer and closer, lowering you closer and closer into my embrace.
You don't remember the way the fog took over you completely and swallowed you whole. You don't remember, do you?
What am I? Of course a mere mortal would wonder these things. I'm a witch, of course. And it's your lucky day. You, my sweet mortal.
Get to become my pet. I haven't had a mortal captive in so, so long. They're so fun to toy with. But so easily broken.
So, it looks like you'll be my new pet.
Oh, you want to know what happened to the last one, do you?
Well, let's say they didn't quite survive the night. You may call me Mistress, for I am your master of sorts. You'll be staying with me for the time being.
And I will be doing experiments on you. My sweet, tasty mortal. Maybe I should call you more slowly. I could just eat you.
What kind of experiments? Well, that would ruin the fun, wouldn't it?
But first, let me get you out of these chains. Have you even noticed that they were there? You probably didn't. You seem pretty daft for a human.
Do you think you're good enough?
To come out of your chains? Maybe. If you begged. I can be quite merciful when I want to. But only if you beg. Go on. Don't want a pet's beg. Be a good pet.
And do as you're told.
Obey me. Obey me. Obey. Obey.
Well, you obey. Fine.
I have you bound quite tightly. I apologize. It seems like some of these chains will leave a mark. Perhaps it bruised.
It is what you deserve. You are nothing but your mortal, insignificant, unnecessary.
A waste of space. Powerless. I don't even know how your kind lasted so long.
You're nothing compared to my power, as you'll soon find out. I'm very tempted to make a meal out of you. You do work quite scrumptious.
So many chains. I got a little carried away. Honestly, I didn't need to tie you up at all, but I get bored sometimes. I like to add a little bit of spice when I play with my toys.
Please beg more. You know, I haven't had human in quite a bit. It is fun to hear you're pleased to not be eaten.
But there's much I have to do before that.
Come here. Now that you're freed, I will allow you to look around so you may look at your predicament.
I have placed you near my cauldron. I think I'll be doing some experiments on you. Some will be pleasant, maybe. Some will be terrifyingly painful.
But the fun part is, you get to pick, but you don't know what does what.
Oh, how fun, how fun indeed. Isn't it so fun? Isn't it just grand?
Alright, let me move you a little bit so that you can see what's going on around you.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow. Let me move myself to the side, just so you get a general idea.
Don't worry about the eyeballs. You don't have to ask where they came from. It is of no bother to you.
But this isn't when I'm going to show you. Let me move first to the side.
But welcome. You'll soon be ending up in this pond. The eyeballs have petrified. I think they sound quite nice, don't you?
Alright, let me move you a little bit so that you can see what's going on around you.
Wow, wow, wow.
Alright, let me fix some bad eyes for a human. Don't you? Ooh, can I make it purple? That's fun.
Huh, seems like I can't fix the greeniness. It is what it is. Oh, unless I just do that.
Can I change the color? I want to make it purple.
What about the other one? Yeah, purple. Oh, ooh. I know what to do with some of the east.
Look at which is the west of the east.
My nails are really cool.
Let's listen to some petrified eyeballs showing.
You're falling deeper under my spell, aren't you? You don't even know it. I'm just pulling you closer.
Deeper and deeper and deeper.
But anyways, let's move forward.
Sorry, I just had to run to my itchy pantry to grab some items.
I love to do that.
I have some items here.
I even have my spell book. And you'll get to choose the spells.
Lots of different spells to go through.
And my extremely fancy and not branded grimoire.
What should I do to you first?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
Pick a number 1 through 11.
It's so funny that you thought you had a choice. I get to pick you silly freaking goose.
Anyways, let's see.
Hold on, the ghosts in my castle are being quite noisy. Give me just a moment.
Oh yes, I found it. The spell to draw out your blood from your body. This is a good spell. Very, very good spell.
I might need to grab some more items.
I need some moonlight dust.
The grimoire requires 4 spoonfuls.
Don't worry, I'll keep you alive with my powers while I drain your blood. You'll feel a little bit of pain, but not too much. You'll still stay conscious.
I'm totally not using my teeth to open this.
Let's see. 4 spoonfuls of moonlight dust.
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Let's put you over here.
I almost forgot the twilight nectar.
Wait, no, I can't do that one. I have other methods to remove your blood.
Don't look at the titles. That's a lie.
This might be a little painful, but I'm not sorry.
I need water from my magic fountain, which you can probably hear in the distance.
I can't read. These rooms are unusual. What is a fluid ounce? Who knows, truly.
Don't worry about that. The hobbits are being silly again.
Sorry, it's taken quite some time to measure this out. Very unusual rooms.
Milliliters? No idea what that is.
Perfect. I think I got it just right. No, you cannot have any of my magic fountain water. It is not for human consumption.
Why is it salty? I probably shouldn't eat that. What can I spit this out?
Don't worry about it.
It looks like spray. I don't know what you're talking about.
Where is my rose elixir? I need six drops of the rose elixir.
I need scissors. Who needs scissors when you have teeth? Me, because this isn't working.
This wasn't a part of my initial idea. I saw it at the store and I wanted to do it.
Three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven, eleven
I'm not a dork
uh huh, yes, indeed, actually I gotta get some unicorn piss, I mean gold
it's fresh, I milked it myself
I didn't check to see how much I was supposed to go with
there we go
might have spilled a little
I don't know why I thought you guys would be able to see this in my really bad webcam
don't worry about it
it looks nice
anyways I've drawn the blood from your body
now I will drink it
quite good
delicious, even, I'm spilling it everywhere
don't worry about it
now that you're bloodless, I can move forward with the neck
with the neck part of the ritual
you're pretty
well that's kind of sparklier, do you have some fey in you?
sorry, I had to go into my infernal dishwasher
so I can get a bowl to dump stuff into
anyways, next
now I must remove the bones from your body
this might take a little bit more
the bones from your body
they will appear in my cauldron
I need some fairy breeze
you got all of your bones
even the one that you think is not a bone
actually is
what do they call it then?
let's see
fairy breeze
four spoonfuls
and it mixes up like this
one, two, three, four
and then I need to pour in some more of my mystical fountain water
I will create my own slime army
and we shall pour this in
fabulous
they're being drawn to the cauldron
take the bones
boil, boil, take their bones
liquefy them and put them in my cauldron
remove them, remove them, remove them
need a little bit more fairy breeze
and I have liquefied your bones
that's awkward
I think that's what I'm gonna try to do
quite nice actually
your bones are fun to play with
how does that make you feel?
I can put your bones against your ears and you can't do anything about it because you're melting
how does it feel to get your bone taken?
here I'll make it into a bone again for you
I'll make it into a bone
looks like a bone
yeah
yippee
that exploded
sorry there's some more bone in there
I need some unholy napkins
that's what this machine needs
alright now that I've removed your bones and blood
we go on to the next
I took your life for me
I'm going to take your emotions
you'll be able to feel nothing anymore
except for feet
nothing but emotions
I need some forest rain
here it is
forest rain
it's important for, I should probably wash this out
yeah
that's good
ooh
you will become a blob
you will become my slime
you'll become part of my slime army
unless you look tasty
because then I'll just eat you
okay
I need
what is it
ten milliseconds of forest rain
let's see
perfect
pour that on in there
get in
just a little bit
there a little extra
I need a drop of star shine
don't ask me where I got the star shine from
alright
you know what my favorite kind of sandwich is
you might think it's a sandwich
but it's a sub
a drop of star shine
I'm using my familiars clippers
that's a little more than a drop it's fine
I need a little drop of sky blue
what is sky blue at
hmm
can I zoom in
because you guys are little scaredy cats
and you like to hide away
whoa
wow
I was so much zoom
so much zoom
alright then
we need mermaids spray
I'm gonna eyeball this
wait the
oh wait the capsule on
mermaids spray
sucking the emotions from your body
so that only fear remains
hope is gone
mermaids spray
what's wrong with mermaids spray
hmm
get out
oh some of you are green with envy
oh
looks like I've gotten some sadness
and some happiness here
mostly a lot of jealousy
let's do it else I can draw out
gotta make sure I put the caps back on things
hmm
looks like there's a little bit of rage and love
oh it looks like more blood
interesting
tell me what do you see
oh there's a great darkness within you
good I like that
oh
um
well
I discovered something
it uh
it does that
and I think I can
I can pop it
oh
this is quite nice to touch
your emotions are fun to play with
that sounds funny
oh it did pop
well
that's what's left of you
emotions are like puddy in my hand
where did my unholy napkin go
I had it I don't know where it went
now my hands are covered in your sad emotions
I found it
oh my gosh
this is a lie
alright
and now
I have to make you fall in love with me
so you'll do whatever I ask
even if that means going to your death
let me find the spell for that
the only emotion that will be left
is your obsession for me
am I out of dragon drops
oh
perfect
let's do it in here
I need a little bit of mermaid spray for this one
the only thing that will be left is your devotion for me
how does that make you feel
how does that make me love that my wings
25 milliliters
it opens better
perfect
I need some extra of the rose
that's the two drops it's fine
they won't know it
they really really won't
and now
let's see a little bit more
it looks like wine
and then
what is it
oh
perfect
I need one more thing
bubbles are rising in it
let's see what I can take out
oh it's just some of your organs
oh that's awkward
it's almost like spaghetti
I forgot about these
I forgot you guys
I have little organs
that would be quite interesting
and I think these are your veins
that makes sense
let me just pluck those over there
oh is that the heart
nope that's not it
that's not what I'm looking for
and ooh
oh here's the heart
hold on
that looks like a heart
what do you think
you want a bite
I'm going to eat your own heart
I'll put it in my hand for you
so you can see your heart
I'm going to crush it
it's very squishy
I'll save that for later
I'll eat that
this is turning green
this is changing a lot of colors
I also might have someone shuck in the process
don't worry about that
perfect
I'm going to get some more now
I'm actually going to towel
an unholy towel
towel, towel, towel
I'm going to wipe off all this mess I've made
let's see
is there anything else that I was missing
fabulous
alright
for the peace there is a stops
I have some magic crystals
that I will use to finalize
your love for me
and your obsession and devotion
where will this eat you
we'll see how this goes
come closer child
come closer mortal
I need more water
where did my special mixing spoon go
family
I need even more
more water minions
more water
I think this ASMR was just more of an excuse for me to be able to do more fun stuff
honestly the latter half of this stream
I will probably cut with the first portion of the stream
and push them together
because those are really the only ASMR part
you must drink the soup
of the eyeballs
so you know what I'm going to put you right over here
yeah that's better
now I'm nice and close to you
I almost forgot this special ingredient
boy
the soup is coming along quite nicely don't you think
hmm
let's see
I got the
the
into the fog once more
you
Let yourself go to the mist. Give yourself to me, human.
You have no match for me more, though.
The fog will pull you in, and you will become one with it.
A bodyless being wandering hopelessly for eternity.
You are under my spell. You are completely hypnotized.
Forever serving me.
Forever serving me in this stress.
Don't worry, I know my craft.
You have entered a higher plane of existence. Now you're worth something.
Maybe I won't need you after all.
Forever serving me in this stress.
Stay with me forever.
Live and love me for all eternity.
Falling deeper and deeper under my spell.
Becoming obsessed and utterly devoted with the heavy rotation of this spell.
Forever serving me in this stress.
Eternally.
Forever serving me.